hello guys I'm Greg
Tony Gill hey Tony Aldo Jones our friend
Aldo he emailed me something I did thor
ragnarok exclusive haircut deleted scene
is weird viral by Aldo Joan and here I'm
ready to see this is up beating around
the bush he's treating on Instagram oh
yes end up beating around the bush
there you go
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow they get it in you take a dish I am
in this rope dude you did it perfectly
yeah this looks so good
[Music]
whoa man Wow Wow
these are just going in that a blonde
hair flying around
oh I hit it again really good a lot of a
lot of that looked really good when the
doors open and Edward Scissorhands was
behind him and doing that was good and
he found the right key to do the head
where Scissorhands clip with Matt for
the hair gray when he got the scissors
to go right to the hair like to make it
look like it really is going through
before such chopping yeah so like damn
and like I was thinking it was gonna
still show leaves or I had gonna be the
hair but when you put in the blunt hairs
like him so I can even edit that into it
was really dope that actually the the
fro right before he had the short hair
that revealed it looked like it blended
really well Matt editing's gotten a lot
better
I've been watching ever Scissorhands
behind them like this looks really good
ever since to seem that Eddie Murphy is
beauty in BH and really clean cuttin the
first couple of them you're just like
all that there it is there's a spot that
you could spot were spitting something
in right there but a couple of the
videos being like later into is like
yeah I could have actually been I'm not
too sure like that's what I was thinking
at the beginning of this because he
showed like the actual clip so I was
like am I supposed to be spying
something right now but it was actually
just all about the haircut
all right Alberto Jones you did it
subscribe to Aldo Jim so it's good I
have is a real rejection if you want to
that's really your call Tony's tree on
Instagram that's the former neighbor
Aldo hormones you got mind kicking and
that's for sure you bone scone I love
you how though I'm homo for Aldo that's
for sure here's my dildo for you sent
him a lot of minutes is just like even
even hitting him up a lot and I'll know
that because he shows me constantly like
he's like hey look look I said I just
sent him a message it says Aldo Jones
equals dildo bones that's a great show
because why you use this penis just give
me a dildo